what i want to do in this video is
really think about what happens when we
define a function and actually what
happens as we step through the program
and we use the function so let's say we
we write this program just like we did
in the last video and we run it so we
the interpreter will start at this first
line over here says oh look there's a
function definition we're defining the
function factorial what i'm going to do
here is i'm going to make a big box and
this big box is the environment and an
environment for a program is all of the
different
definitions and variable definitions and
everything that are specific to what or
the context that the program is running
in so immediately the program will
associate the name factorial with this
whole function right over here so right
when it says define factorial it'll
actually associate it'll actually let me
write over here
it'll actually associate factorial
it'll actually associate factorial
the label factorial i guess you could
say it
it'll associate the label factorial with
a function with a function that looks
like all of this business right over
here so you'll pass it a number
you'll pass it a number
and i'm not using well maybe i'll write
it like this it's a function
it's a function
and i'm not using the you'll see
different notations lambda notation and
all this fancy stuff if you take a
formal computer science class but all
i'm just saying is factorial refers to a
function that has the parameters
that has the parameters
has the parameters it only has one
parameter it has the parameter number
and then when you and then given given
this function with the parameter number
it will then it'll then process this
code right here it'll then process this
code so let me just copy and paste it
right here and then
oops i'm doing it in the wrong i'm doing
it in the wrong layer let me copy it and
paste it again so let me
try to copy it
let me copy it and then let me paste it
so that's what's it's doing right over
there and actually i should make this
box the environment includes all of this
i think you'll bear with me i didn't
draw this orange box big enough the
first time around
see let me do that just so that no one
gets confused
just so that no one gets confused let me
expand the orange box
and i erased a little bit parameter one
of the parameters is number
is number and then that orange box goes
around the whole thing
that's a green that's green that's a
green color not a green
all right here we go
so right when we hit that this first few
lines it's saying look in our entire
global environment there's this we're
defining a function the factorial will
now refer to a function that takes the
parameter number and then it'll run all
of this code that we've defined here and
then it'll return whatever inside this
function world whatever the value of the
variable product is
and then it keeps going line by line by
line and then we get to this line right
over here and it says the variable user
input is equal to
and then it calls the function input and
it passes the function input and i'm
trying to use a little bit of
terminology that we've been exposed to
it passes the function input a string so
this right here is a string and once
again string sounds like a fancy word
but it literally means string of
characters or this text right here the
text enter a non-negative integer take
the factorial of colon space so even the
spaces are part of the strings and the
the telltale sign for string is it's
going to be inside some type of
quotation marks either double or single
quotation marks so by passing this to
that input function that tells the input
function what do what to prompt the user
so it prompts the user with this string
the user types in a number or some type
of expression that gets evaluated and
then gets stored in user input or i i
really should say in the python context
user input refers to that value so let's
say the user inputs 3 then the variable
user
input then the variable user input user
input
will now refer will refer in this global
environment now factorial refers to a
function user input user input will
refer to
user input refers to
what whatever the user typed in i'm
going to go with the specific example of
three then we go to the next line and
it's saying look make factorial of user
input make this entire variable refer to
whatever we get when we call factorial
of user input factorial of this variable
over here and so this is the interesting
part at this point in the program the
factorial to of user input
this part right over here it will make a
call
it makes a call to this function
it makes a call to this function and
this and it gives it the argument of
whatever user input is now user input is
referring to 3
user input is referring to 3 so it is
going to pass 3 to the function
factorial so 3 gets passed here and
essentially within this function world
so now let's say that this is the
context of running this function so
within this function world
let me make it clear so now within this
function world right over here the
functions environment
the variable number
the variable number within this function
world now refers to
now refers to that same
it now refers to 3. now i want to be a
little bit i now want to be a little bit
careful because we're we're starting to
touch on the idea of scope of a variable
the variable number the variable number
in this function world it is only
referenceable within the function we do
refer within the function it is not
referable outside of the function so if
i if down here someplace i would say
print number you would get an error
because it would be out of the scope of
that variable this this variable it's a
parameter to this function it's only
usable within this function it's scope
the place where you can refer to it is
only in this function
so you get that number and then it does
the code that we've looked at before it
sets the variable product it it the
product
so
product the variable product now refers
to the number one
then it calls all of this code and since
we talked about scope i'll talk about
another situation scope this variable i
is only valid within the scope of the
for loop if down here i said return i
that would have given an error you can
only refer to it within the for loop
and we've gone through this code
multiple times it goes from i equals 0
to i equals 1 to i equals 2 all the way
up to i is equal to 1 less than the
number but since we're adding 1 to i
every time it's really going from this
whole expression right over here starts
at 1 then 2 then 3 all the way up to the
number and each time we're multiplying
it times the original product to get a
new product so at the end of the day
product after we go through this whole
for loop product will contain the
factorial of the number
so the product will contain the
factorial
factorial of
the number so within so after you do
this product will keep referring to a
bunch of things it'll refer to one then
it'll refer to two a two then it'll
refer to six because we're going to do
three times two so eventually product is
going to
product is going to refer to
is going to refer to
is going to refer to 6 and then that is
returned and that is return and when i
say that that is returned that means
when you evaluate this entire thing over
here when you evaluate this entire thing
over here that entire thing is going to
be is going to be six and then that lets
once we get out of that program it lets
it lets the interpreter know that
factorial of user input
that factorial
of
user
of user input
should now refer to that 6. i know this
might be a little bit confusing with all
of this diagramming but i really want to
get the sense of what's happening
user input is referring to something we
pass that something to the factorial
program so then we go up here and within
the factorial program now since we
passed user input and user input was 3
within the factorial program this is
number is going to refer to 3 and then
we run this as if number was three and
then we return product which is going to
be the factorial of number and so this
whole thing evaluates to the factorial
of whatever was in here so the factorial
of three and so factorial of user input
this variable will now refer to that
because it's being assigned to that and
then we print it and when we print it
that's what actually shows up down in
our interpreter so hopefully that
doesn't confuse you too much in the next
video we'll we'll discuss how we might
be able to do interesting things to this
function itself